Hey,
Shinsuke, I didn't expect you to leave my friend behind.
That friend asked me to do it. Everyone, run
away right away. Run away. I smell a dragon.
Somehow, it's a dragon. No way, God! Oh no, the dragon can't do that. The
dragon runs away.  What is the punishment for
accepting the suicide of a shogunate servant by the God of Desire?
Where is the evidence of such a curse killing a shogunate servant who will be exterminated on the spot? First of all, I am on a mission. I do
n't need any evidence. Just justice will be done.
You are the one who attacked the main temple.  I
'm sorry for my inexperience, God King, but you've learned your lesson.
Did you run away from your long-cherished wish?
Well, it won't last long.